[Music]
here are some other Hollywood moms that
are showing off their fit summer bods
and how to get them I've been craving
these workouts so muscle memory is a
real thing because it's still under
there gotta get rid of yes parts is
there fish in my thighs but we're
working on it
Chloe's doing meal replacement shakes
and quite literally worked in her
Kardashian butt off using resistance
bands in her supercool home gym but we
love that she and Tristan still do grab
McDonald's from time to time fellow new
mom Anna Kournikova went from this to
this twenty two weeks after having twins
she's spending lots of time working out
so is Dancing with the Stars Kim her
javac who's using her babies as weights
the 41 year old also told us she wore
support garments when she left the
hospital now she's doing Pilates and
dance cardio
how's Kelly Clarkson dropped 37 pounds
clean-eating Kelly had a thyroid issue
since 2006 but credits the book the
plant paradox for getting her back on
track
the best part zero exercise it's not a
secret I just read a book and yeah it's
called the plant paradox yeah you do
look amazing though well it's basically
about rethinking everything how we eat
processed foods how we spray our food so
it's it's really it's a really great
book that chunk changed my life but I'm
not saying it will change yours
[Music]
[Applause]